hey here we are again
we're not everybody's sleeping yeah i'm
not hungover
i'm just sleepy all that [ __ ] with like
you know taking all the aspirin and
drinking all the water before you go to
sleep that doesn't actually work
and i even woke up a bunch of times
because i had to pee like a bunch of
times
last night sophie's still [ __ ] up she
doesn't want to come on the show
we're talking about your sophie she's
talking about you live she's like no i'm
talking about don't talk about me yeah
we can make up all kinds of stories of
all kinds
she'll probably yell tomorrow yeah cause
we're gonna do a movie review we're
actually gonna do a movie review today
but the show went on so
late last night we were all so drunk
that even had i watched the movie i
probably wouldn't even remember it
so uh we'll watch the movie tonight and
review it tomorrow so today we'll just
do
a [ __ ] sidetrack show
yeah it looks like you're drinking a
urine sample is that apple juice no it's
apple juice okay
well i had some i had some apple juice
earlier too we need to go to the store
we didn't go to the store
i know well we could just get done with
the show we'll go to the store let's
write it out
god it's been raining all day like
really really bad like
blowing [ __ ] against the thing so one of
the things that we once said because
like i can't really think of anything to
talk about because not that much has
happened
but um this was a funny thing so
i we probably mentioned before how
when we get up and we you know you take
a shower or whatever and then you go in
the closet
like to get dressed and pookie gets all
excited and she runs in oh hey poke
we're just talking about you
yeah um and she runs into the closet
waits for you you know
because it's like she wants the wet
towel thrown on her she wants like you
know somebody to play with her
so i went in there with her this morning
and i laid down on the floor and she
like kind of cuddled up in my chest and
was like purring and i was like petting
her and stuff
and sometimes um i sing her like cheesy
songs
but i replace some of the lyrics with
pookie yeah you know what i mean like
you do like i think a lot of people do
that with their animals
so normally i guess some of the classics
that i would use i'd do
uh neil diamond right then i said i did
neil diamond
i did uh some berry manilow today for
whatever reason i started singing uh
abba's dancing queen
except it was pookie queen obviously and
so i started singing the abba song and
she very deliberately
got up and walked right out of the
closet
i was like what so yeah no no i was like
so i could sing neil diamond to you and
bury manilow
and like [ __ ] like that and that's fine
but abba was just that was a bridge too
far
yeah and she's like i'm not listening to
abba i'm out of oh bless you
i'm out of this closet right now and
then um
then i was like putting my makeup on and
tom you were still in bed though yeah
but you were awake and uh you started
saying like david bowie songs
with pookie in there yeah which the the
funniest thing i was there putting my
makeup on and you started singing
little china girl yeah the little pooky
girl it was a little pookie girl but the
best part of it was when you got to the
part of the song
where you know where david bowie says
something like she says shh
like that except you did the noise that
pookie makes like
everyone i [ __ ] lost it she says
because that's the noise she makes
that's what she makes yeah
you just touch her
[Laughter]
yeah she doesn't she doesn't open her
mouth you know what i mean it's like a
purr but it's like a [ __ ]
meowth it's like a whirring sound yeah
and like i said i think we've mentioned
before like
um it's it means different things like
depending on the tone
of it you know what i mean yeah it's
like sometimes it's just like hey
but then sometimes it's like hey chase
me you know what i mean it's like she
gets like super excited like she'll run
by and go yeah
like a little train or whatever so then
we thought
that we should make like a whole yeah
i don't have the technical expertise to
do this but
we we were like we should make like a
youtube channel where we redo
all those all the david bowie videos
except with pookie in them
yeah and we would change the words put
pookie's face on david bowie's
body and then i'll re-sing them with
pookie-centric lyrics yeah
see i would like that very much i think
that would be very funny crazy
i know are you why are you fighting with
me
yeah i don't know if it came out on the
on the thing because sometimes it's not
like loud enough unless she's like right
next to the thing
yeah but um and then that made me
remember like a couple years ago i
posted on facebook
that she used to have when we had the um
the shelves of dvds like in the room
like it's in the closet now
it was in the bedroom and if she ran out
of treats in the middle of the night
because we have a little like ceramic
dish in there that we put treats in for
her to eat
and uh if she would run out in the
middle of the night she would go up on
the shelves and she'd start pulling
all the all the blu-rays off and like
throwing them at the bowl like so they
would make noise like she would
just like scoop them and like throw them
onto the bowl so they would crash
um to tell us that it was empty so for
whatever reason like one morning i just
had a flash
of inspiration and i wrote an entire
song to the tune of old time rock and
roll
except it was about her pulling all the
dvds out
because she didn't have any treats and
like how badly she wanted treats
and that i put everything in there i put
the [ __ ] about how sometimes you throw a
pillow at her when she does it but she
doesn't care
and it's like it was the best and i i
was like
goddammit did i save that so i looked up
on i looked up on facebook and i did
indeed save it
so i was like pretty happy about that so
i just like pasted it into a text that i
could like so i'm like
that was pretty funny i'm gonna have to
say that i don't like that song though
bob seeger what have you got to say
for yourself oh me yeah not much
[Laughter]
i'm still kind of worn out from last
night actually yeah me too i'm actually
really like cause like i said i woke up
i woke up a bunch of times i didn't i
didn't feel bad like i didn't feel
hungover i just had to like
i had to pee a bunch of times because
you know what i mean so i kept like i
woke up like every two hours like having
to go to the bathroom i gotta
we gotta go to the store too we do yeah
we don't have any food suitable for
these vegans
vegans like vegan yeah
well what yeah what do we need to get
there well i'm almost out of vodka i
have to go to the liquor store i can do
it too
i mean i don't want any vodka tonight
obviously like probably for the next
couple nights because
you know we had a lot although it
it was all right last night because i
feel like i drank a lot but it's like i
still remembered
ending the show and i still remember
like i still kept track of where my [ __ ]
was just [ __ ] long and she's
complaining how long the show is well
you got four cases in here
well like six hours worth of materials
honestly it was
an hour before we even started talking
about the topic so it's like that was
not my
that was not completely bad never start
taking the executive command over this
[ __ ]
look at what's the case is first what
you have planned to go
no no no no and [ __ ] and
at least whittle some of this work down
for you because
that show was [ __ ] twice as long as
it should have been
probably just saying well like i said
when i made when i did the notes like
the [ __ ] that i wrote down about each
case was not
a lot i just you know yeah but i know
how slowly we go through that material
in a normal course of a show i think
everybody'll like that
that was that was definitely a show for
the ages i think well because i mean i
could have got two shows out of that i
could have like cut it off at the end
but i was like god damn it i wrote down
like all these four cases and i am going
to talk about all four of these
after a couple hours after a couple
hours i started getting too tired i
don't know what i mean and like
for me i feel like my energy is starting
to wane
yeah i mean although i did talk about
how beta i get
yeah there's all kinds of funny [ __ ]
that was but that wasn't in the last two
hours that was in the first two hours
yeah i think you know what i mean i had
to get i had a good time on that i
wanted to keep the show around two hours
it was just so funny it was so funny
that like i was talking i was like
concentrating on my notes and stuff and
then we realized that sophie had not
come back from where i just thought yeah
the [ __ ] she goes i just thought i'm not
feeling good i always thought she went
to the bathroom and i thought she was
going to come back and then i realized
like i was like well hey she's not going
to be pouring the drinks man you worry
i'm not feeling too good
[Laughter]
and then we were still and i still can't
believe about [ __ ] dennis's head
coming off
yeah i'll fix it i broke down yeah
i don't know that glue i have is really
good hopefully it'll work if not i'll
have to do it with a dab screw
something threaded mango badger came on
and said you know it looks like i missed
a good one last night i have to catch up
with it later it was like a really fun
one i had a good time and like i said it
was [ __ ]
five hours long yeah um so hey
i kind of think it's fun like i want you
to fix dennis because it kind of bums me
out that he's like
broken but um in a way i was like
wouldn't it would it kind of be funny
too like if we made it a thing
where now we can just like talk to
dennis's like disembodied head
yeah and then he could just like go up
here and be like
[Laughter]
[Music]
well that's what i mean he would be like
a lot more mobile yeah
you know portable he's a lot more
i'll be at the grocery store shopping
and i'll [ __ ] pull that shirt wow
well you know
[Laughter]
what happens with the beans and rice
everybody's buying it everybody's buying
up all the deborah
they're pretending like it's the
apocalypse everybody decided they wanted
to bake breads
yeah bread can't find any damn bread
flour
everyone will bake bread now you know
yeah well yeah everyone's really bored
thank you
wow you know brad is brad you know
flower
yeah mangoes like who broke dennis tom
did
yeah [ __ ] bro he had we
[ __ ] watch last night videos man i
got a [ __ ] documented we haven't brought
it out for so long and we brought him
out because sophie was the one that
bought him for us
this is what you do this is what you do
what you do is you take
that clip right and you re-engineer it
make a special called the death of
dennis
and it's like a little [ __ ] news
report [ __ ] news report
i have people mourning and [ __ ] start
grin you just get pictures of people in
india morning
and [ __ ] people in russia mourning
people like dennis has died
that would be okay oh my god
he does that girl in the orange best
when trump got elected she's going no
you put that on her as the [ __ ] is
his headphones as i break his head
i mean you couldn't really see it
because you dropped it on the floor
but you could see my reaction but you
see his reaction to it i dropped it
and then and then you know sophie goes
oh it broke and i was like what
yeah his little head just fell right off
can we get rick says can we get out and
about dennis photos
we could take him with us like put him
out in the yard we'll put him like we'll
lay him like in a little bitty like sun
chair i can put little [ __ ]
sunglasses on him and [ __ ] like that
yeah put a little [ __ ] party hat on
him
oh look at sophie in the comment section
i know sophie's in the comments section
why she's in the other room over here
in the room next door watching the show
come here sophie we scared her
[ __ ] man it was too weird i guess it was
too weird being
on the show when you're used to like
watching from the other side
i don't know it's really weird no i said
i was gonna say somebody's afraid of
becoming famous
they're all gonna they're all gonna
laugh at me they're all gonna laugh at
you
that's okay people can laugh at me all
they want i'll give a [ __ ]
you know because i don't really care
about what other people think of me so
you know
but um we need to make dennis i mean
next week is my birthday week
next saturday is my birthday we should
make dennis a party hat oh [ __ ]
we should make him a little it'll only
take a second you just like make it with
a [ __ ]
marker or some [ __ ] like that's like
some white paper or you can make it out
of like i have some pretty wrappy paper
you can make them like a little [ __ ]
party hat and he can come to the party
he can sit on the cake i'm getting
a cannoli cake [ __ ] don't you
gonna get it from the publix bakery
that's what i want they have like i mean
if you guys are not in the south and you
don't have
publix i mean that's like the saddest oh
my goodness
pookie she's laying in the back can you
can we see her
can you see her no she's laying on her
back she's crazy yeah get
get the okay
yeah yeah laying on your back poop hi
sweetie what you doing little pooky girl
she says
i was still laughing about that [ __ ]
with the abba thing because like i said
usually
i'll sing to her like i talked to her
and stuff like that she's just like yeah
she just like takes it but as soon as i
started saying it abba she was like oh
no
i'm not having this yeah so you know
sophie they're all in the comments
section [ __ ] calling calling you back
we're gonna have to well i mean we
stream like almost every day so it's
like she's gonna have to be on some of
these
yeah probably i mean we're gonna be
we're gonna do a movie review tomorrow
because i already have the movie picked
out
you're making me laugh so much that my
eyes are watering like all my [ __ ]
now you can just get it off you could
touch uh pookie's belly
it's not trap it should just be gone
okay all right
well you can actually put your face in
there and bite it yeah within reason
i'll put my face in her belly and bite
and she'll just go
and then she'll grab her and then she
grabs her head she'll grab it on a
little bit but then you know she
she knows it's all fun and games yeah
she's i mean she's been with us since
she was
a tiny tiny tiny kitten so and no one
has ever
hurt her no one has ever done anything
bad to her so
she i mean like i said tom like wrestles
with her we can roll her up in the rug
yeah
like through the rug and she like comes
flying out she loves it
she loves it well she does it once and
she goes back to the end and lays down i
want you to roll her up in the carpet
again and then just
throw her out and she goes rolling out
like that and then she looks at you like
it was a little tailwind and then she
gets
she'll go to the end of the carpet so
just her head
what are you doing i'll push her back in
there and then
she's funny yeah that's the kitty
burrito ride yeah she loves that [ __ ]
yeah she used she used to do like cirque
du soleil [ __ ] too like on the curtains
but she doesn't do that anymore yeah and
she doesn't like you to unroll her
slow i'll do that yeah she lets me just
experience that's not a good one
that's not a good one it's gotta be fast
yeah she's getting her out
and she goes and then like it says she
rolls
[Laughter]
she's the funniest [ __ ] cat ever we
have to make her a party hat too
we're gonna need everybody has to have
party hats
dennis has to even if he's just ahead
dennis has to have one
pokey has to have one she won't wear it
no it took it it took us forever to get
her to like wear a little collar like to
go to the porch
are you falling asleep poop your balls
late oh my goodness a little bit yeah
her little head's upside down
yeah i'm sleeping
all right so um wait you want to go to
publix and get yeah we got [ __ ]
we have to get some vegan adjacent food
we are kind of i'm out of yogurt i'm out
of everything
yeah out of booze yeah a lot of orange
juice yeah
god damn it all right
so uh we will be back tomorrow streaming
at 3 p.m eastern standard time like
usual like i said tomorrow we'll do a
movie review
we'll try and like talk sophia coming
back out i don't i'm not i don't want to
make her come on or she doesn't want to
come on because i know some people don't
like to be
on video and especially like especially
live
and stuff so if that freaks out i don't
want to like she's afraid she's going to
become famous
people send her messages and [ __ ] she's
like messaging me
well yeah but it's like you can just
ignore that most of the time
i mean i don't i don't ignore it because
most of the messages i get are nice but
it's
like you know if some jackal messaged me
i'd just be like
no they were nice nobody's senator beam
message okay
she just she's shy
ken says did you see the light or a
picture moved yesterday in the replay
about 42 minutes and 28 seconds no where
on on last night's video let me go look
oh i didn't see that i saw i think i
remember like i just
like glanced at a message and saying
that i was like oh i got a check and
then i didn't check
i don't know maybe you did do some
poltergeist [ __ ] in the background and
wouldn't even notice it
maybe oh no we'll see
i'm going to that video yeah alex says
publix never win dixie every now and
then we go to winn-dixie if they have
like um
if they have a snake special yeah
usually if they have crab legs on sale
because sometimes they have like
and and they have crab legs really cheap
the win dixie
near near where we live the one that we
go to has been rebuilt
it's it just isn't physically it's just
as nice as publix yeah it's been i mean
when i was
when i was growing up when dixie was
like kind of it wasn't like the
ghettoest
store um that would have been like
albertsons or food lion
like especially i mean where i grew up
but um
yeah all the winn-dixies now have been
like redone
all right now what time does it start 42
minutes and 28 seconds
that's what he said behind tom over his
right shoulder
yeah so see if there's some kind of so
we'll see
maybe we'll know what it is if you like
configure 42 what now 42.28
okay it's come all right it's 42. oh
this is so exciting it's like ghost
adventures
it's over my shoulder yeah over the
shoulder
28 yeah i see a
what do you see this little red light
right there okay 42 12.
okay coming up on 42 20.
one two
the red light he said i see it
it went from side to side ooh
um is it do we know what it is no hold
on let me go back on
a mystery now i'm gonna now i'm gonna
have to go on my big computer and look
and see what it is let me look at it
again
let's see what he's talking about
watch watch that oh i know what that is
watch it
oh oh we did it
yeah one two okay okay that's
interesting well okay i know what it is
it's that
reflecting off of that but it shouldn't
have moved
unless maybe somehow my foot hit it
maybe okay i see what you're talking
about
but
that doesn't qualify the real [ __ ]
phenomena is a lot [ __ ] better than
that
when you see it you can't deny it rick
says
danny says look at us paranormal
investigation
i'm not gonna i'm that's interesting but
i don't think that's it
yeah because i mean i know that that's
definitely because we have like a
pinkish
like reddish pink light like right there
and it bounces off
that wall and bounces back there on the
back of that bauhaus poster
and that's what the light was but maybe
yeah maybe you kicked it
like the table that it was on and it
moved
although it looked like it was swinging
which is very strange
like i don't i don't even know how
how it would have had the light like to
bounce all over there like that
i don't know how to happen that's very
weird yeah because it's not is it
reflecting
red on there now a little bit right now
just a little bit they're like right
there
because i think the lights have been
moved around a little bit since last
night because we had to bring in like
extra chairs and [ __ ]
i don't know it's pretty weird i don't
think that's it though
yeah next if we do do poltergeist [ __ ]
like make sure that it's something like
definitive going on back there like i'm
just
you know saying yeah poultry guy stuff
is a lot more dramatic than that
that's what i mean make like a full body
apparition yeah then we'll see that
no it would be like tearing something up
or throwing something
wouldn't that be something if we were
like [ __ ] recording the show and like
the on-air sign just went phew
yeah or some crazy [ __ ] like that in my
experience it's something that's it's an
object that's always unobserved though
i'm not sure if it can do it with a
camera on it yeah but we're not looking
at it directly
so yeah but the camera's looking at it
and other people are looking at it
which means it's not in a it's not in a
state of like quantum
[ __ ] you know i mean it's not and
it's not like a quantum uncertainty
about what its location is
yeah like when you seen things [ __ ]
fly off
we were looking in the same direction
but not directly at it that's true
yeah anyway we gotta go yeah he's
getting cranky yeah
he's getting cracky all right so we will
be back uh tomorrow
um have fun watching the five hour show
last night in case you missed it it was
super fun
and we'll be back tomorrow to do a movie
review so uh we'll see you next time
bye